when we're looking at data sources
the easiest first place to start is
existing data sets
conceptually the easiest way to do this
is with in-house data
also in terms of existing data there's
open data and there's third-party data
i'll talk about the pros and cons of
each of these briefly
in-house data can be fast and easy
because it's already there
it might be in the proper format and if
you're lucky it's documented properly
on the other hand in-house data may not
be subject to the kind of quality
control the data that's intended for
other people might have
also there might be restrictions or
policies on the data use
even within a particular organization
so let's look at some of the pros and
cons of in-house data
the first pro is potentially it's very
quick easy and should be free
because you're within the same
organization if you're lucky there's
standardized formatting that the
organization has instituted rules or
policies about this is the way we do it
also if you're very lucky the original
team that gathered the data and
processed it should still be available
makes your life very easy when you want
to answer questions and get insights
sometimes identifiers might be available
and what that means is you might
actually know the identity of each
respondent or case in it
there are however some cons first off as
the data you need simply may not exist
it may be the organization never
gathered that data
also the documentation may be inadequate
often when organizations are gathering
their own data they get it together
they use it for what they need to and
then they kind of store it off to the
side
but it's hard to tell what's what and
also the quality of the data may be
uncertain
you may not know about response biases
or errors in coding
and that makes it a little harder to
work with it reliably
an alternative to in-house data is open
data
this prepared data that's freely
available
usually it's government data but there's
also some open corporate data
and there's a move towards more and more
open scientific data
now the pros here are that you can get
enormous data sets
you could get terabytes possibly even
pita bytes
that are worth millions of dollars you
can get a very wide range of topics
you can get them covering various
historical times and trends
and the data from open data is often
well formatted and well documented
the cons of open data are that you
potentially have biased samples
in that the samples may be restricted to
a particular geographic area or may be
restricted only to people that have
internet access
and those can create problems with
interpretation
also the meaning of the variables may
not be clear
you don't have the opportunity to talk
with the people who gathered the data
and it's sometimes hard to understand
why or how they defined a particular
variable the way they did
also in some situations open data may
stipulate that you need to share your
analyses
that open data is there for open
analytics
that might be an issue and something you
need to look at carefully before you
dive in
finally openness and data can conflict
with the needs of privacy and
confidentiality in data
finally there's third party data or what
we call data as a service
these people are also called data
brokers and you can get a huge amount of
data on a large range of topics
also many of these data brokers will
also process the data to make certain
kinds of inferences for you which can
save you a lot of time
so the pros of third party data is that
they can save you a lot of time and
effort
they often give you individual level
data
and you can get summaries and inferences
on the other hand
third-party data can be very very
expensive
also it may still require validation
you still need to double check that it
means what you think it means
and probably most significantly third
party data
is often very distasteful to many people
so our conclusion exercise care and
interpreting data
because there's always the possibility
of implicate biases or simply because
you weren't there when it got gathered
it may not mean exactly what you think
it means
that being said you can get enormous
amounts of information
and you can save yourself a lot of time
in your data science projects by using
existing data sets